prime minister albanese you have
announced a public holiday to mark the
queen's death why was that so important
to you
i think it's important that we
commemorate the remarkable life and
indeed uh the service that queen
elizabeth gave to australia as our head
of state
for 70 years the longest serving british
monarch ever
but also a great deal of affection
from australians towards the queen
and on thursday the 22nd of september uh
protocol requires the
national remembrance day to be the day
after myself and the governor general
the
the now king's representative in
australia return
from the service in london
uh so here that will occur in parliament
house at the great hall i've declared it
a national day of mourning and together
with the states and territories we
agreed yesterday to have a national uh
one-off public holiday
the australian's relationship
with the queen appears enduring
what do you think it was about her reign
that achieved that special connection
i think the the queen was with
australians during times of celebration
the opening of this house parliament
house in 1988 the opening of the sydney
opera house
during
our great historic events
but was also with australia at our times
of difficulties
this is a land of cyclones or floods of
natural disasters
and queen elizabeth always reached out
uh to give that comfort uh to
australians at our time of need and she
was such a a respected figure
regardless of where people stand on the
political spectrum that 70 years of
public service that that devotion to
duty
is something that holds her in in such
high regard
how do you think the dynamic will change
under the reign of king charles
well of course it's the end of the
second elizabethan era and the beginning
of a new one
king charles of course is very well
known to australia he did some of his
as a student here
was in victoria
he's someone who's been a regular
visitor to our shores i think on a range
of issues as well that king charles has
expressed opinion on over the years not
party political opinion but opinion
about humanity's direction the need to
take action on climate change the
relationship uh with the built
environment and its relation to our
natural environment
king charles of course is very familiar
to all of us
and today
we have proclaimed him the king of
australia
part of the success of queen elizabeth
reign here seems to be that people
perceived her as being politically
neutral do you think her son
will be able to achieve that too
i'm sure he's very conscious
of the need to be
above politics and he certainly has
always been that in terms of of
australia
but he's someone who has a
a deep relationship
with australia
i hope that he is able to visit here on
on an occasion as as soon as as possible
but he's been a regular visitor here and
we're very familiar this
of course is it's a substantial change
the the only monarch
that we have known in my lifetime and in
the lifetime of most australians uh has
been queen elizabeth
so this is a change one of the
the reasons why i think
queen elizabeth is held in such
affection is that if you think about the
last 70 years it's been
an era which has seen more change than
any era in human history
the nature of technology and the way
that it's transformed the way that our
society functions uh queen elizabeth was
able to
change uh with with that times in terms
of her her interactions uh with
the public
and king charles will i'm sure do the
same it's reignited a debate about a
republic
do you think in this moment that that is
appropriate or perhaps even
opportunistic
well i i am of the personal view and
i've made it uh
clear that now is the time for us to pay
tribute
to the life of queen elizabeth ii to
give thanks uh for her service to
australia to the commonwealth and to the
world and that is the focus that i have
you've talked about the need previously
to have an
australian head of state but you said
you won't commit to a referendum in your
first term is that still the case
you thought my priority and i uh said
this before the election and i've
maintained it since my election as prime
minister
is the recognition of first nations
people in our constitution
our constitution at the moment would
have you believe if you
read it it's our nation's birth
certificate that history began
in 1788
and of course that was an important part
of our history but we are home to and
share this continent with the oldest
continuous culture on the planet that
goes back some 65 000 years that should
be a source of national pride
and we should recognize aboriginal and
torres strait islander people in our
constitution that is absolutely my
priority
when it comes to the monarchy do you
think though australians want to see
the institution
evolve
uh well of course and and it has evolved
and it will continue
to evolve
it will need to continue to move with
the times
but the bigger questions about our
constitution are not ones for
this current period
this is a period in which
we are showing the grief that so many
australians are feeling at the moment
showing our deep respect and admiration
for uh the contribution of the queen uh
to australia and today of course the
the transition uh formally here uh to
recognise that uh with the queen's
passing uh king charles automatically
became
the head of state of australia
but today we're formalized that with the
ceremony one of the things about
i think the queen's affection that she
was held in as well
is that
there is that tradition
and
we've
gone through those processes
here in australia in the last
few days it's a sad time but it's also a
time to celebrate
what is a long life well lived
you will be attending the queen's
funeral you'll be meeting with the king
how do you want to see your relationship
with him i look forward i look forward
very much uh to meeting
king charles
i have met him before in his uh his
previous capacity
and i had the honour of meeting uh queen
elizabeth at buckingham palace
and prince charles was there on that
occasion at the first meeting
of of the g20
and i look forward to on behalf of
australia expressing uh face-to-face
person-to-person
uh my condolences and the condolences of
our nation for the loss
not just of course of
queen elizabeth as
the head of state
but as his beloved mother and i thought
it was a beautiful statement that king
charles made in his first statement as
as our new sovereign
do you think this moment this pause for
reflection internationally might
actually consolidate people's belief in
the power of the
monarchy i'll look that
that we will see
what occurs uh i think the important
thing is i think to commemorate uh
the moment that we're in now
and it is a moment of reflection
about an extraordinary life
and
one of the uh the videos i saw this
morning i remember seeing the
uh the joke video that the queen
did with paddington bear recently
and that says something about her
character as well that's one of the
reasons why australians who were a
pretty relaxed lot
uh can really relate i think so well uh
to
the life of queen elizabeth
and she certainly had a powerful
connection and we've witnessed that
first hand here in australia and
just to confirm though no no referendum
in in your first term
no that's great thank you so much prime
minister i really appreciate you
speaking with us
and um
something we we saw yesterday was just
the amount of people who talked about
her enduring legacy no matter
what people's perspective on the
institution may have been flowed waned
over the time
she in particular seemed to really
garner
a lot of respect and love her well
that's right um i think that
australians might have different views
about the full range of views about the
institution uh my views are there
very much on the record
but regardless of that
i don't think that gets in the way of
an admiration and respect
for
queen elizabeth and for her contribution